hi everybody so in the previous video we
talked about reinforcement learning and
introduced the general paradigm and the
problems that we have with sparse reward
settings now in this video I want to
dive a little bit deeper into some more
technical work that tries to solve this
problem of the sparse reward setting so
I hope you will remember from the
previous video that the thing that makes
reinforcement learning so difficult is
that we're dealing with sparse rewards
which means that for every input frame
we don't actually know the target label
that our network should produce and
therefore our agent needs to learn from
very sparse feedback and sort of figure
out by itself what action sequences led
to the eventual reward and one
particular solution that has been
emerging from research is to augment the
sparse extrinsic reward signal that is
coming from the environment by
additional dense reward signals that
need to aid the learning of the agent
and so in particular in this video I
want to dive into some interesting
technical work that introduces ideas
like additional reward signals curiosity
driven exploration and hindsight
experience replay are you ready for a
technical deep dive into
state-of-the-art reinforcement learning
my name is Andrew and welcome to archive
insights
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so in order to solve some of the most
challenging problems in reinforcement
learning we have seen the emergence of a
wide range of new ideas in reinforcement
learning research and one particular
trend that has been very popular
recently is to augment the sparse
extrinsic reward signal that is coming
from the in-game environment by
additional feedback signals that need to
help the learning of your agent and many
of these new ideas can be seen as
variations of the same general concept
so instead of having a very sparse
reward signal that your your agent
occasionally sees we want to design
additional feedback signals that are
very dense or in a sense we want to
create a supervised setting and the goal
of those additional rewards there was
additional feedback signals is that they
are in some way related to the task that
we want our agent to solve so we want to
create these dense feedback signals that
whenever our agent succeeds in those
tasks it's probably also going to get
knowledge or feature extractors that can
be useful in the eventual task the
sparse tasks that we can really care
about and so obviously there's no way
that I can give you guys a complete
overview of all the super interesting
research that's going on out there but I
try to sketch a few very interesting
papers that try to give you an idea of
the general directions that we're seeing
in research right now so let's start
with auxiliary losses so in most
reinforcement learning settings our
agent is presented with some kind of raw
input data like sequences of images for
example the agent will then apply some
kind of a feature extraction pipeline in
order to extract the useful information
from those raw input images and then it
will have a policy network that uses
those extracted features in order to
perform a task that we wanted to learn
now the problem in reinforcement
learning is that our feedback signal can
be so sparse that the agent never
succeeds in extracting useful features
from the input frames and so one
successful approach in this case is to
add additional learning goals to our
agent that leverage the strengths of
supervised learning to come up with very
useful feature extractors on those
images so let's take a look at one
specific paper from google deepmind
called reinforcement learning with
unsupervised auxiliary tasks so here the
standard sparse reward signal is that
our agent is walking around in this 3d
May
and it needs to find specific object and
whenever it encounters one of those
objects it gets a reward right but what
they do is that instead of having this
very sparse feedback signal they also
augment the whole training process with
three additional reward signals so first
the agent learns to do what they call
pixel control so given a frame from the
environment it uses the main feature
extraction pipeline and it learns a
separate policy to maximally change the
pixel intensities in some parts of the
input images so for example it could
learn that by looking up at the sky for
example this completely changes all the
pixel values in the input C and in their
suggested implementation the input frame
is divided into a small number of grids
and a visual change score is computed
for each grid the policy is then trained
to maximize the total visual change in
all the grids and the idea here is that
this will force the feature extractor to
become sensitive to the general dynamics
in the game environment the second
auxiliary task is called reward
prediction and so in this case the agent
is given three recent frames from the
episode sequence and it's tasked to
predict the reward that will get in the
next step so again we are adding an
additional learning goal to our agent
that is only used to optimize the
feature extraction pipeline in a way
that we think is generally useful for
the eventual goal that we care about and
then there is one final task called
value function replay which basically
tries to estimate the value of being in
a current state by predicting the total
future reward that the agent is going to
get from this point onwards so this is
basically what any off policy algorithm
like DQ n for example is doing all the
time and so it turns out that by adding
these relatively simple additional goals
to our training pipeline we can
significantly increase the sample
efficiency of our learning agent and
especially the addition of the pixel
control tasks seems to work really
really well in three-dimensional
environments we're learning to control
your gaze direction and how this
influences your own visual input signals
is very crucial for learning any kind of
useful behavior all right now the second
thing I want to look at is something
called curiosity driven exploration and
the general idea here is that you want
to
somehow incentivize your agent to learn
about new things that it discovers in
its environment so in most default
reinforcement learning algorithms people
use what we call epsilon greedy
exploration and this means that in most
cases your agent is good is just gonna
select the best possible move based on
its current policy but with a small
probability of epsilon is going to take
a random action and then this epsilon
starts out at 100% in the beginning of
training so it's completely doing random
things and as you train as you keep
progressing it's actually going to start
declining this epsilon value until in
the end you completely follow your
policy and the idea is that by doing
these random actions your agent is going
to learn to explore the environment and
now the general idea behind curiosity
driven exploration is that in many cases
an agent can quickly learn some type of
very simple behavior that earns a
recurring low amount of rewards but if
the environment is hard to explore a
simple agent using epsilon greedy
exploration will never completely
explore the full environment in search
of better policies and the idea isn't to
create an additional reward signal that
incentivizes the agent to explore unseen
regions in the state space and so a
standard way to do this in reinforcement
learning is we will recall a forward
model so this means that your agent is
going to see a specific input frame it's
going to use some kind of a feature
extractor to encode that input data into
some kind of a latent representation and
then you have a forward model that tries
to predict that same latent
representation for the next frame in the
environment so basically it's going to
try and learn the dynamics of its
environment where based on what I'm
seeing now what is going to happen next
right and so the assumption is then that
if your agent is in a place where it's
been many times before these prediction
losses these predictions will be very
good but if it's encountering a totally
new situation it has never seen before
then it's forward model will probably
not be that accurate and then the idea
is that you can use these prediction
errors as an additional feedback signal
on top of the sparse rewards - you know
incentivize your agent to explore unseen
regions of the state space and so one
particular paper that I want to
highlight here uses what the authors
introduced as
intrinsic curiosity module and uses a
very good example to show what this all
means so imagine a scenario where an
agent is observing the movement of tree
leaves in a breeze now since it's really
hard to exactly model the breeze
predicting pixel changes for each leaf
is going to be virtually impossible and
this means that the prediction error in
pixel space will always remain high and
the agent will be forever curious about
the leaves you need to
and the underlying problem here is that
the agent is not aware that there are
some parts of the environment that it
simply cannot control or predict okay so
here is what the intrinsic curiosity
model in the paper looks like the raw
environment States s and s plus 1 are
first encoded into feature space using a
single shared encoder network next there
are two models you have the forward
model which tries to predict the
features for the next state using the
chosen action from the policy and you
have the inverse model that tries to
predict what action was taken to go from
state s to the next feature state s plus
1 and finally the feature encoding of s
plus 1 is compared with the predicted
featuring coding of s plus 1 given by
the forward model and the difference
which we could call you know the agent
surprised about what happened is added
to the reward signal for training the
agent and so going back to our example
of the tree leaves
since the motion of those leaves cannot
be controlled by actions of the agent
there is no incentive for the feature
encoders to actually model the behavior
of those tree leaves because in the
inverse model those features will never
be useful for actually predicting the
action that the agent took and therefore
the resulting features from our
extraction pipeline will be completely
unaffected by irrelevant aspects of our
environment and we will get a much more
robust exploration strategy so in the
paper they benchmark there our method
using a maze exploration so you have a
very complicated maze with the target
position and your agent needs to
navigate around the maze to find that
goal and you can see that as they
increase the size of the meso the
complexity of that maze all the methods
that do not use intrinsic exploration
methods kind of fail if the maze gets
too big but you if you incentivize your
agent to explore unseen regions and it's
much more likely that it's going to
eventually find the reward and so I
think this is a really clever idea that
instead of just thinking about ok I want
to get to this goal position I want to
get this reward your agent should also
you know it has to be curious about the
world it needs to explore things that it
doesn't know about in order to you know
increase its general knowledge of the
environment so really cool idea and
again this is just one paper
working in this area but I think a lot
of people are realizing that getting
your agent to efficiently and
intrinsically explore your environment
is a very crucial part of learning
alright another very beautiful extension
to the standard reward setting is a
recent paper from opening I called
hindsight experience replay or in short
and the idea behind her is very very
simple but very very effective so in
sense I'm a really big fan of the paper
because of the simplicity of the idea so
you imagine you want to train a robotic
arm to push an object on the table to a
specific target location the problem
again is that if you do this by random
exploration it's very very unlikely that
you're gonna get a lot of rewards and so
it's going to become very difficult to
train this policy and so the general
solution to do this would be to shape a
dense reward which is for example the
distance of the object to the target
location in Euclidean space right so
that way you have a very very specific
dense reward for every single frame and
you can use simple gradient descent to
train this now the problem is again as
we've seen that reward shaping is not
actually the solution that we want to
use we would like to do this with a
simple sparse reward you know success or
no success
and so the general idea behind hindsight
experience replay is that they want to
learn from all episodes even if an
episode was not successful for the
actual tasks that we want to learn and
so hindsight experience replay applies a
very clever and very simple trick to get
the agent to learn from unsuccessful
episode so in the beginning of learning
the agent is pushing around an object on
the table and it's trying to get to
position 8 but since the policy is not
very good yet the object ends up at
position B which is not the right thing
this is not what we wanted so instead of
just saying hey you did it wrong you got
a reward of 0 what her will do is it
will pretend as if going to be was
actually the thing you wanted it to do
and then telling it yes very well done
this is how you move the object to
position B you're basically creating a
very dense reward setting from a sparse
reward problem so let's go over the
algorithm step by step so we start off
with a normal off policy reinforcement
learning algorithm and a strategy for
sampling goal position
right we initialize all the parameters
that we need and we start playing some
episodes so given a specific goal
position we're just going to use our
current policy we get a trajectory and
we get a final position where the object
ended up in so after our episode has
finished we store all those transitions
in the replay buffer with the goal that
was selected for the policy but then we
also sample a set of modified additional
goals and we swap those out in the state
transitions and then store everything in
the replay buffer and the really nice
thing about this algorithm is that after
training you now have a policy network
that can do something different based on
the goal that you give it so if you want
to move the object to a new location you
don't have to retrain the whole policy
you can just change the goal vector and
your policy will do the right thing and
so in the graph here the blue curve
represents the results from hindsight
experience we play when the additional
sampled goal was always the final state
of the episode sequence right so it's
the it's the actual position that the
object ended up in after executing a
sequence of actions the red curve which
is even better represents the results
when the additional goals are sampled
from future states that are encountered
on the same trajectories and now what I
like so much about this paper is that
the idea is very simple and the
implementation of this algorithm is very
simple as well but it addresses this
very fundamental problem in learning
which is that we want to use every
single experience that we have as
maximally as possible so in summary
we've just seen a few very different
approaches to augmenting sparse reward
signals with dense feedback that I think
hints at some of the first steps towards
truly unsupervised learning
but despite the very impressive results
that we've seen there are still a lot of
really challenging problems in
reinforcement learning so things like
generalization transfer learning
causality into physics I mean these
problems remain as challenging as ever
but I would like to end this video by
stating that I think reinforcement
learning has tremendous potential if you
think about an autonomous robotic
assistant in your house these things
might still seem like science fiction
today but I think the reality is that we
are currently in the process of solving
some of the most fundamental challenges
in autonomous learning much the same way
that we had to do in supervised learning
people came up with algorithms like back
propagation or techniques like
convolutions for example I think that by
looking at the impressive pace of
progress over the past few years and the
sheer amount of intellectual capacity
that is working on these problems
I think breakthroughs could come
surprisingly fast and so obviously the
darker side of this very exciting
research is that many of the jobs that
we have today will be subject to a large
degree of automation an inevitable
transition which I think will create a
lot of social pressure and inequalities
and it's probably one of the biggest
challenges if we want to create a world
where everybody can benefit from the
advancement of artificial intelligence
so that was it thank you very much for
watching I hope you learned something
and I'd like to see you again
in the next episode of archived insights